[Music]
on this Monday night out of control the
threat of a new fast-moving wildfire in
BC we're in a stage four drought what's
igniting the flames
a murderous plot foiled the woman
accused of wanting to assassinate
Ukraine's president
moving migrants the UK's controversial
tactic to repel Asylum Seekers
and Iron Man we are making good stuff a
Montreal blacksmith's vital role in
helping rebuild Notre Dame in Paris
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight para Nasser good
evening to you thanks for joining us
long weekend thunderstorms have been a
double-edged sword bringing much-needed
rain to parched areas of British
Columbia but also lightning and strong
winds intensifying the fire situation
there more than 40 new fires were
sparked in BC in the last 24 hours
bringing the total number to more than
400. most of the new fires have been
caused by lightning but as Heather
York's West explains investigators
believe a human-caused fire triggered
the Urgent evacuation of a five-day
music festival near Princeton last night
all day Monday they flew back and forth
planes delivering water to a new fire
near Princeton BC
from the highway Sunday night it cast an
eerie glow
dangerously close to this outdoor
Electronic Music Festival hundreds in
attendance were forced to flee we went
out there with a uh the Princeton Posse
the junior hockey team we took the bus
out there expecting to bring home a
busload of people we only end up having
to bring one back everybody else found
another another ride out of the out of
the area the Wildfire halfway between
Princeton and tulamine was spotted just
after 8 30 p.m Sunday one of 400 fires
now burning across the province we have
seen an increase in Wildfire starts as a
result of some lightning activity that
affected large parts of the province
both in the North and the South
officials say lightning caused 40 new
fires between Sunday and Monday 30 are
out of control but the fire near
Princeton is believed to be human-caused
and if convicted those responsible could
face fines and jail time as well as any
Associated cost associated associated
with
extinguishing responding to that welfare
while rain in the Northwest part of the
province is a welcome help more soaring
temperatures are forecast for BC's
interior it's been extremely hot it's
it's dry it's we're in a stage four
drought here which is uh one step away
from the worst drought condition we can
get so the rivers are pretty low Lakes
are pretty low which adds to the the
fuel load a warning that even with so
much of this province on fire there is
still plenty of Tinder dry fuel left to
burn Heather York's West Global News
in Southern California three people have
been killed after two firefighting
helicopters collided midair last night
one of the Choppers was able to land
safely the other crash killing the pilot
and two firefighters on board the crash
sparked a small brush fire which has
been put out the national Transportation
safety board is investigating
the fires in California are the result
of wide-ranging severe weather across
the U.S from tornadoes in several states
to Historic flooding up in Alaska right
now 120 million Americans are preparing
for intense storms on the East Coast
while the South bakes in extreme heat
Sophia pirani has more
Wicked winds turned devastating in
Illinois overnight
mowing down homes and trees with
reported tornado sightings there and in
Colorado that is a tornado funnel now
the U.S national weather service is
warning Washington Baltimore and much of
the Appalachians towards Tennessee face
a level four of five risk of damaging
winds hail and Rain the federal
government even authorized an early 3 pm
departure of its employees ahead of the
storm there goes there goes in Juneau
Alaska historic glacial flooding
triggered evacuations dramatic video
shows a home being Swept Away what came
to a surprise to us was the amount of
water that came out of the Basin we
never saw this amount of water at once
come out of the Basin as millions of
Americans across the continental U.S
experience some form of extreme weather
or disaster climate change is playing a
part in many of these events including
the severe underlying heat sweltering
the South where alerts stretch from
Calif fornia to Florida
off Key West researchers are rushing to
save the vulnerable coral reef so by
relocating these corals to deeper cooler
Waters we hope that they'll have an
increased chance of making it through
the coming weeks back on Lounge the heat
and humidity has killed hundreds of
livestock in several States and in Texas
those temperatures are causing Peak
energy demand like extremely extremely
hot here in Houston with little sign of
it letting up in August Sophia Perani
Global News
severe weather is also affecting South
Korea where the world Scout Jamboree is
now being relocated
about 36 000 participants from 158
countries including Canada are being
moved away from the path of a tropical
storm expected to make landfall
Wednesday the event was already being
criticized over poor conditions in
extreme heat causing hundreds of Scouts
to fall ill and others to leave prior to
today's evacuation order the Jamboree is
still on until the 12th at a soon to be
determined location
and Ukraine a woman has been detained in
connection with an apparent plot to
attack president velodimir zielinski
according to the government Ukraine's
Security Service claims the folds plan
is linked to reconnaissance work related
to zielinski's visit to the mikalaya
region last month the suspected
operative has not been identified as
Crystal commencing Reports it's not the
first time the president has come under
serious threat
it was business as usual Monday for the
Ukrainian president but he did mention
on his telegram page that he was briefed
on the struggle against traders in
Ukraine
the country's Security Service
spokesperson says on the eve of a visit
to the mikolaiif region a Russian
informant was trying to collect
Intelligence on the president
[Music]
these images are from Vladimir
zielinski's visit to make a lie of last
month but it's not clear if this was the
trip the alleged Russian operative was
using to learn the locations times and
routes the president would be traveling
officials shared this obscured image of
the woman in question but did not
release her name
they were tipped off about her and
launched additional security measures
including counter surveillance plots
against zelenski are not new the
secretary of the National Security
defense Council told global news last
year that on four occasions he had to
tell the president about possible
assassination attempts
his reaction is annoyed or again he says
but I have to tell him
it's not known how many more attempts
there have been since that interview but
the president travels a lot more now and
is more visible compared to the early
days of Russia's full invasion
what hasn't changed is the toll the war
is taking on families Ukrainian
officials say one woman died when Russia
hit this building in the hersan region
early Monday
Ukraine as a part of its
counter-offensive is fighting to reclaim
recently lost territory and
long-occupied regions like Crimea on
Sunday it hit two bridges in that area
including the Chona Road Bridge
Rob Hubert is a military strategist
because you have this this overlap
between the political military means I
see this particular element of the war
intensifying this is where there's going
to be some very increasing fighting
because the stakes are so important for
both sides with a push to reclaim
territory and the foiled assassination
attempt the updating of the motherland
statue in Kiev with the Ukrainian
Trident serves as a larger than life
reminder of the need for defense but
also victory
Crystal commencing Global News London
Russia is set to evacuate an entire
Village for the country's first lunar
lander mission in nearly half a century
the lunar 25 Lander will launch from a
site roughly five and a half thousand
kilometers east of Moscow nearby
residents will be told to leave on
Friday in the rare chance of falling
rocket boosters after they separate the
main objective of the mission is to
develop soft Landing Technologies and
research the internal structure of the
Moon
the airspace over Niger closed coming up
what the country's coup leaders are
trying to prevent plus the UK's new
controversial way of deterrent migrants
coup leaders in Niger have closed the
country's airspace until further notice
citing concerns of military intervention
from neighboring countries a deadline to
reinstate the democratically elected
president expired over the weekend Q
leaders rejected the ultimatum set by a
block of West African nations that had
threatened military action a
spokesperson for the Junta said the
armed forces are ready to defend the
country if necessary the flight tracking
website Flight Radar 24 showed no
aircraft in niger's airspace on Monday
the countries will meet again on
Thursday to discuss the political
situation
the UK like other countries is dealing
with a record number of Asylum Seekers
and it has turned to a controversial new
measure to deal with the crisis
authorities have started putting people
on board a housing barge in the south
coast of England the government says
it's being done to save money and to
make the country less attractive to
migrants but human rights groups say the
barge is unsafe the UK's firefighters
Union has called it a death trap and is
Redmond Shannon reports some say it
could also re-traumatize refugees
these were the first Asylum Seekers
boarding the Bibby Stockholm a 90 meter
barge destined to be a floating home for
500 men in 220 rooms some local Brits
don't want it near their neighborhoods
others say What's Happening Here
shouldn't be happening anywhere the way
that the government has been running
their Asylum policy is set up to Target
these people and to scapegoat them there
are more than 50 000 Asylum seekers in
British hotels costing UK taxpayers 10
million dollars a day last year so a
record number of people using small
boats to cross the English Channel 45
000 the British government says its
barge plan is intended to deter more
from following what it sends is a
forceful message that there will be
proper accommodation but not luxurious
um luxurious Hotel accommodation has
been part of the pool I'm afraid the
barge is Central to prime minister Rishi
sunax stop the boat's policy as our
efforts to send Asylum applicants to
Rwanda and according to new reports the
tiny Ascension Island in the middle of
the South Atlantic the Rwanda plan is
stalled and the Court's human rights
groups say it and the barge are inhumane
re-traumatizing and ineffective when
people are fleeing in security and
poverty their own research tells them
why people cross and it's because a they
can't get Visa access and B they have
family or links and ties in the UK the
UK like Canada is dealing with a housing
crunch alongside a backlog of Asylum
cases currently more than 100
000 applications in Canada with Asylum
Seekers now sleeping in Toronto churches
mayor Olivia Chao has asked residents to
offer up affordable rental units people
are opening up their hearts
they're opening up their wallets
we're asking the federal government that
you also need to do the same by Monday
afternoon just 15 people had boarded the
barge with last-minute legal challenges
blocking about 20 other transfers and
planned barges in other UK locations
face more objections too sunak hopes
this is the boat to help stop the boats
but achieving that appears to be far
from smooth sailing Redmond Shannon
Global News London
Stella had the legal battle over the
handling of
[Music]
it three years after George Floyd's
murder sparked a reckoning over racism
and police brutality a former
Minneapolis officer has been sentenced
on state charges
a Minnesota judge sentenced to Tao to 57
months in prison for his role in the
murder he was convicted in May of aiding
and abetting second-degree manslaughter
he's already serving a three and a half
year prison term from a federal
conviction his new sentence will happen
concurrently Tau held back bystanders
while former officer Derek Chauvin
kneeled on Floyd's neck in May of 2020.
he testified he was merely serving as a
human traffic cone but the judge found
his actions objectively unreasonable
saying Tau had a duty to intervene
there are more legal troubles for Donald
Trump over his third indictment related
to election interference after the
former U.S president wrote troubling
social media posts over the case
prosecutors filed a protective order to
prevent him from releasing or discussing
evidence today Trump's team called for
the order to lessen its scope to Shield
only genuinely sensitive materials as
reggae reports the legal battle could
determine what evidence is seen and what
is heard in the upcoming case
never one to bind his tongue Donald
Trump's defense is focusing on the
process and not his legal problems so
this uh ridiculous indictment
against us it's not a legal case it's an
act of desperation but his words have
prosecutors worried a flurry of vaguely
threatening social media posts resulted
in the special counsel asking for a
protective order on shared Discovery the
concern that Trump could spill secrets
and influence Witnesses it's not at all
unusual for a judge to reign in a
defendant who is going to try to bring
this case to the public essentially try
it in the court of public opinion even
before it gets inside of a courtroom and
well it's a common practice it also
leaves room for Trump to claim he's
being silenced I think in Trump's mind
his legal strategy is his political
strategy still legal experts argue this
case is more about speech than conduct
speech Trump's team says is protected
but also hidden behind a new front line
claiming Trump never directed anyone to
do anything illegal and that his
comments are merely aspirational the
first amendment protects political
speech higher than any other speech even
once staunch allies of trump are weary
about this new approach well it's
certainly a challenging case but I don't
I don't think it runs afoul of the First
Amendment also on the mountain of
motions being considered our requests to
get the case out of heavily Democratic
Washington and away from a judge
appointed by Barack Obama so if you
can't beat him you persecute him or you
prosecute him Trump appears to be
hinting to his supporters that he can't
get a fair trial in Washington while
making no fuss over his Florida Case
overseen by a judge he appointed and
still to be determined is whether a ban
on cameras in the federal courtroom will
be lifted Trump's legal team and even
house Democrats are calling for Access
saying that it will allow for the public
to better digest the information during
the trial and an eventual outcome while
helping to control narratives
pharah ready to Kenny in Washington
thank you Reggie
[Music]
an excellent day for an exorcism
Academy award-winning director William
friedkin has died at the age of 87. some
of his best known Works include The
Exorcist To Live and Die in LA and The
French Connection for which he won best
director his wife says friedkin died
from a heart failure and pneumonia at
his home in Bel Air today
[Music]
Barbie hi Barbie
director Greta Gerwig has called her
Barbie movie a feminist film and now she
herself has smashed a glass ceiling
she's become the first female solo
director to surpass a billion dollars at
the global box office barely three weeks
in something the film's star and
co-producer Margot Robbie predicted and
pitched to Warner Brothers while trying
to get the green light for the fantasy
comedy though Robbie admits she thought
she was overselling
[Music]
forged in fire next how a Montreal
blacksmith is helping restore the Notre
Dame cathedral in Paris
[Music]
back in 2019 a devastating fire ripped
through the Notre Dame cathedral in
Paris severely damaging its roof and
Spire since then experts have been
working to reconstruct the historic
church which is now on track to reopen
to the public next year and as Elizabeth
zagalis explains a Montreal blacksmith
is playing a key role in the restoration
project
tucked away in the peel Basin sits an
old pumping station that was built in
1887. inside the building not much has
changed since the 19th century we are
making good stuff which lasts long in
time frame and this is a corresponsible
Mexican
translates to
I went to France in 1994 to 1998 as an
apprentice
and I came back to Quebec in 98 with the
ID to create a museum and a school for
preserving intangible knowledge of a
cultural heritage of traditional
smitting
Colette has been doing his trade for
more than 30 years but comes from a long
line of blacksmiths I'm the fourth
generation of Andre Malta Vern lines of
a family which my master was a third
generation so he teached me
what I've been lost in France Colette
uses fire coals and traditional methods
to make tools from Iron and Steel his
specialty is axes because I've learned
there and I win some prizes the the
government of France sometimes need me
to go back there his skill is so
specialized last year he was asked to
help a team of blacksmiths in France
recreate axes that were used in the 13th
century to build the Notre Dame de Paris
Cathedral there was a first session in
September a second session in October
and a third session in December and we
had made around 20 axes at each session
a massive restoration project is
currently underway in Paris after a fire
in 2019 destroyed the roof and Spire of
the famous landmark they still using the
Carpenters who are making the timber
Framing and the red oak of Notre Dame
are still using those axes to finish the
job
here in Montreal Colette and his team
have a passion for showing a younger
generation their trade
every first Sunday of the month visitors
can head to the site and watch Colette
in action everyone is welcome to come
visit at leforge Memorial and be in
touch with that science which is our
history Elizabeth zogales Global News
Montreal
and that's global national for this
Monday night I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our whole crew I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your Monday
evening with us tonight's your candidate
is Buren Newfoundland and Labrador we
love senior Canada so please keep
emailing us your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and take care of each
other good night
thank you
[Music]